good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how to deal with
negative people the second rule is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for my
thoughts and some special bonus clips as
well and as always if somebody says
something that's really deeply
meaningful to you or really helps you in
some way please leave in the comments
below and put quotes around it so others
can be inspired as well enjoy it's
necessary that you detoxify your life
that you have to look at your life and
look at the people in your life and Jim
Rohn set ask the question what is this
relationship doing to me see most people
never live their dreams because they are
saddled with too many toxic negative
energy draining people in their lives
God look at the people around you and
asked is this this relationship is it
helping me to grow mentally emotionally
financially spiritually on a financial
part MIT did a study you earned within
two to three thousand dollars of your
closest friends it's necessary if you
are serious about your dream that you
detoxify your life
dr. Dennis Kim rod of Atlanta if you are
the smartest one in your group you need
to get a new group what I heard that I
got all the broke people out my life
because people rub off on you John H
Johnson who had a loan of five hundred
dollars from his mother and built a four
hundred million dollar Empire with ebony
magazine and Jet magazine fired his best
friend and and the report asked why did
you fire your best friend he said he
told me I couldn't do it he's in hell
how do you think I could do it I need
anybody on my payroll to tell me so you
have to look at your life and say hey
who's in my circle who's in my ear
let me tell you my thoughts about number
one thing you should do when you got to
deal with negative people use it use
their energy use that energy they put
out there use that challenge for your
own character development really see
what I've some is negative around me I
don't sit there and I don't become a
victim oh gosh they're such negative I
don't go home and assume their energy
and now I'm negative instead I go you
know what this is a moment to test am I
really in command of my emotions and how
I think or are they am i giving my power
over to the world so that they can just
take my energy and turn it to what they
want or am I in charge so I use it as a
challenge not as something I don't have
to challenge or change them immediately
I'll get to that point but I get to the
point where say you know what huh here's
a little challenge of world's throwing
me right now can I stay on my game can I
stay centered
can I stay peaceful can I stay calm can
I stay present right here right now and
not have to run away from it not have to
pretend it's not there but use it and I
encourage you to do that because if it's
just something that you immediately
complain about well then in your
complaint you you just let them win
their negativity has turned you into
noticing what is negative and you lost
you're not winning even if you can
critically you know throw a barb at it
make fun of it you're still losing
you're being sucked into their pools of
pessimism you're drowning
so I say use it recognize it and use it
know that your own frequency that you're
broadcasting out is the most important
thing to protect in other words if
someone wants to be negative over there
then yeah and that's the signal they're
broadcasting very similar to a radio
station if you're setting your car right
now you can tune in to a myriad of
different stations now they're all
playing simultaneously all around you
the question is who do you want to tune
into if you want to tune into people
that are in your environment that are
negative if you start listening to
somebody that's broadcasting at radio
we'll then you're going to be singing
songs very shortly even if you don't
like the music you're gonna be starting
to hum or sing those songs or tune in
and get depressed game over if you are
in an environment where somebody is
broadcasting that you need to start
listening to something a little more now
you can broadcast your own songs you can
see them know that oh yeah I see weather
out that's their behavior yeah it's not
who they are it's just their habit or
whatever it is I'm grateful that isn't
me send them some love and compassion
and then move out of that environment
if proximity is an issue you work with
the person they're part of your family
then make sure that you're at least
taking time for yourself to log in or
tune into higher levels of frequency
things you can generate you can play
your own song and if you play it louder
than the ones that they're playing in
your mind then it's far less likely that
you're gonna be affected
now one thing you don't want to do my
friends is don't try to change anybody
oh well I just want to make them more
positive or I'm gonna cues them of not
being positive that game doesn't work
right and I'm sure you've already tried
that some of you and know where that
path leads no again if we start to judge
people try to change them we're no
better off yeah we may as well be
broadcasting you're wrong and nobody
hears you're wrong they all hear oh I'm
being threatened as my sense of identity
which I need to then defend and protect
and then have a go back right that's it
doesn't matter what the argument is
doesn't matter who thinks who's right
yeah get off the game of trying to
change anybody except that if they're in
a part of their life where they get
their needs met by being negative then
that's who they are your job is not to
fix them change them or convince them
otherwise your job is to maintain that
your radio signal that you're
broadcasting at is more positive yeah a
higher frequency and therefore no matter
who's playing a radio Saukville
that doesn't affect the song that you're
singing yeah that is yeah by far the
best way to be able to deal with that
and number three is the perspective the
bigger picture a lot of us we may be
dealing with someone at work it may be a
friend even the next-door neighbor and
they
push our buttons we have to first see
that all relationships are mirrors so
what can we learn from this experience
that is fundamental so they are also
showing us things about ourselves so we
have to thank them as well and we have
to see the bigger picture to say it's
not the end of the world there is so
much going on in the world that why am i
focusing on this person because whatever
you focus on gross you turn into
whatever you're tuned into so we have to
see that once you can see the bigger
picture this so-called person who is
making you feel unhappy they just
disappear into thin air a few months ago
I read a book called the happiness
equation by a guy named Neil Paz Rita
and in this book Neel argues that
happiness is 90% attitude and only 10%
circumstance and when I look back at my
own life I agree with this and look back
six or seven years I was definitely less
successful as a freshman in college I
had less money I had a lot more
uncertainty but I wasn't unhappy and I
don't think that I'm a whole lot happier
on a day-to-day basis now than I was
back then because my attitude was
similar both now and then and when I'm
thinking about these concepts of
happiness and attitude and looking at
them through the lens of dealing with
other people as Hanlan's razor leads me
to do I'm reminded of a quote by the
Roman Emperor Marcus Aurelius which I
really want to share with you guys today
now in Roman history Aurelius is known
as the last of the five good emperors
and while he was definitely a great
ruler he was also a great philosopher in
the philosophy of stoicism and his
writings which have been collected in
the book of meditations are where this
quote comes from so in book 2 of
meditations
raelia strikes when you wake up in the
morning tell yourself the people I deal
with today will be meddling ungrateful
arrogant dishonest jealous and certainly
they're like this because they can't
tell good from evil but I have seen the
beauty of good
and the ugliness and it recognized the
wrongdoer has a nature related to my own
nowt of the same blood or birth out of
the same mind and possessing a share of
the divine and so none of them can hurt
me no one can implicate me in ugliness
nor can I feel angry and my relative or
hate him we were born to work together
like feet hands and eyes like the two
rows of teeth upper and lower to
obstruct each other is unnatural to feel
anger of someone to turn your back on
him
these are obstructions I think this is a
really powerful quote I wanted to give
you my little interpretation of it here
basically that 2016 Thomas Frank version
2,000 years later so when somebody is
being jealous or being rude or coming at
you in any sort of negative way you can
realize that you are of the same nature
you are both imperfect human beings
going through imperfect circumstances
within this world and what do you
realize that you can route yourself like
a tree and bend not break because you
realize that whatever they're going
through that is most likely what's
causing them to act this way and once
you do that number one it can set your
attitude and make you a happier person
overall because you've let the
negativity wash over you instead of fuel
to you and make you react and I get away
yourself but number two it can let you
get to the other part of human nature
which is to cooperate with your fellow
human beings and recently a friend said
how do you handle distractive and and
negative people and I'm like look the
thing is the thing is not to just be
positive
not even to offer this no negativity
policy that I talked about the way to
avoid negative and distracting people
managed to vibrate in a rate so fast
okay
that you're out in front of them once I
got a speeding ticket actually here in
Miami and the in the police officer says
oh why are you speeding why are you in
such a hurry I'm like dude I'm trying to
stay away from the crazies okay if I can
just get ahead of everybody else I'm not
distracted by anybody but guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and and
stop my mission see so I got my ticket
and moved on and went to the head of the
pack
yeah see this what I'm telling you man
look if you want to not be bogged down
by negative distracted people you need
to take responsibility that you're
slowing down enough to get caught up by
this magnetic charge of distractive and
negative people do you need to vibrate
so fast that these people are
distracting other people not you get way
ahead of the crowd get so busy that
nobody's gonna jack with you man because
you're filling up your pipeline you're
full you're busy and you don't have this
stuff sticking to you look if you got
negative people around you if you got
distracted people and we all do but if
it's causing you to be distracted and
negative dude you need to vibrate you
need to fill up your pipeline you need
to explode blow up get busy so this
didn't happen in two years you're partly
responsible fill your pipeline so my
quick thoughts on this are one I think
most situations you can take yourself
out of the environment of negative
people I think too many times we have
negative people in our lives and it just
sucks the life force out of you it's
really crappy being around negative
people they kill your ideas you tell you
they can't do something to tell you that
you can't do something they just
complain complain complain complain
complain and the world does not belong
to complainers the world belongs to the
people were taking action or doing
something we're frustrated about
something in our going forward to try to
fix it where if you just hang around
these negative people who are constantly
complaining you know you become a
product of your environment as you need
to be really conscious about that and so
I'd be looking to think of how can i how
can I escape this if I'm around negative
people my number one go-to solution is
don't be around negative people try to
avoid it create a new environment for
yourself where you don't have to be
around these people that's a lot easier
for someone who's an entrepreneur
because we get to decide what customers
we work with what suppliers we work with
what team we hire on board and I think a
lot of people become an entrepreneur
because they're trying to avoid the
negative people that they have in the
other parts of their life where they
have a job before the second air is
where you don't have control you have to
be in that situation where you know you
have that job and you could actually
leave that job and go somewhere else but
you know think about my son who has a
bully in his class understand that you
know for him
yeah we could sure step in and say hey
discipline that bully years or we could
take him to another school but the fact
is there's bullies in every school and
if you're gonna stay in school and you
don't want to do homeschooling that's
part of the process is dealing with
learning how to deal with these people
understand that negative people want
somebody to be an outlet with negative
people need to release it because they
don't want to just complain and be it by
themselves
they need the validation from somebody
else so if you are listening to them
whether you agree with them or not just
the fact that you're listening to them
and given them time given them air space
that's validation for them and they're
gonna keep coming back to you where
really you want to just ignore them not
spend any time with them not acknowledge
them and then they'll move on to
somebody else and so you know is the
advice that I gave my son in dealing
with the bully in his class is don't
don't just don't pay attention to him
he'll then find somebody else to bully
somebody else to pick on somebody else
to be negative around you can go off and
do other things this is also true in
like in family situations if you have a
really negative mom or dad or uncle Joe
or whoever it is I don't want to say
walk away from your family although
sometimes that's the right call but
limiting your exposure and then try to
do something in the rest of your life
where you're surrounded by people who
build you up where you create an
environment of greatness where you have
you know things on your wall and videos
that you watch to now try to take that
equation instead of being all negative
to having a tiny bit negative in like
95% positive so even if you don't have
complete control over the situation that
you're in one hour challenged you to
think do you actually have some kind of
control but let's see me have no control
of the situation then look at all the
other things that you can control in
your environment your habits your
routine your daily practice to overload
it with positivity to help you have the
confidence and courage to go up to that
thing that you want and be the best
version of yourself
so thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because Daniel Rocha or Roca asked me to
hope I got that okay if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover in the next
addition to believe life please leave it
down in the comments and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of the rules
or what did people say today that had
the biggest impact on you how are you
now gonna go out and deal with negative
people and the negative things in your
life a little bit better please share
down the comments below I think it could
help cement the activity for you as well
as inspire other people to maybe make
some changes in their lives so thank you
guys again for watching I hope you have
an amazing day I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is let's love
I'll see you soon
empathize you know a lot of people who
are being in a negative mood or negative
energy you don't know why you know
you've had a bad day too you've been
rude yes I know you're amazing and you
watch this show and you're really into
personal development at the end of the
day you've been rude to people too
you've had a bad day you snap you've
been impatient you've hollered you've
been a jerk when you shouldn't have been
you know it well other people do too so
when somebody is negative always wonder
I wonder what happened today that led to
that you know maybe the kids got out of
the wrong side of bed and they were just
horrible that morning and they that
person didn't sleep last night maybe
something happened with their family
maybe on the way to the work they just
thought of something very depressing in
their past maybe the truth is right now
they're so unclear about who they are
and what they want in life that they're
taking out on other people
maybe their own failures their own
struggles their own disappointments have
ravaged them and led them to you know
depression led them to mental disorder
the reality is we never know someone's
story and once you can teach yourself
that I really believe you become a
better human you become more
compassionate
you're better at listening you're better
able to understand because you have the
intention to sympathize and say oh that
person's really in a bad place right now
you don't take ownership of that say
well I didn't cause it you just say
simply ah they're in a bad place I hope
they're okay you know I think it's a
real true personal power be able to walk
by negative people and still say I wish
you nothing but joy and health and
strength and love in your life to have
that hope for people even when they're
in a bad place that's humanity a great
way to deal with negative people is
always to keep it moving and to keep it
moving you have to see that how is this
serving you because we have to let go
of whatever no longer serves us but more
so we have to see that we've got work to
do
we have to ask ourselves how is this
helping us become the greatest version
of ourselves because once you argue with
a fool from a distance nobody can tell
the difference so a lot of the times we
just have to see that keep it moving
don't let negative people take over your
life some negative people where we're
always gonna have them maybe they help
but positive people keep their feet on
the ground I don't know but be careful
of just laughing at them ignore their
behavior at your peril behind that
negativity could be a cry for help maybe
they are miserable by Nature maybe they
just lack confidence or maybe they feel
a sense of injustice
I'd love to provide you with a magic
wand on how to deal with negative people
I can't but think of it like this in
many respects people's behaviors a bit
like an iceberg and above the surface
you're seeing the negative behavior but
if we can understand a bit more of the
reasons that are causing that in the
first place what's going on below the
surface then I think we will have a lot
more success in dealing with negative
people